all right let's hear from a few more
people we do calls via discord you can
find the david pakman show discord at
davidpakman.com slash discord
let's uh in this next uh tranche of
calls
let's go to
um alexander the texan alexander you
were on the air
hi david i hope you're doing well thank
you
um
so i just wanted to get your take on
something
though i'm seeing with a lot of what i
would call the american bad leftists and
a lot of the general right-wing
two specific stories that they ran
really hard on one of which being
uh allegations of perjury against
anthony fauci that the intercept wrote
about yep the other of which being
excuse me
the uh current
stories about hunter biden
among more of the uh common sense
left-wing channels
i would go as far as the saying it seems
like like this story is being kind of
ignored i would just like to hear uh
your thoughts on this please sir yeah so
i'll go backwards i mean with the hunter
biden stuff
i just don't really get what the story
would be
for me so when i see the head you know i
follow the right wing headlines and i
see that i think it was last week maybe
five days ago a bunch of articles popped
up about hunter biden's emails again and
pictures or whatever i just don't get
what the story is for me i mean he's a
guy who has struggled in his life
he's not only not the president but
unlike with trump because biden doesn't
you know have his his kids working for
him hunter's not involved in government
so i just don't really know what the
story is other than
just that his last name is biden and
he's joe biden's son so that's why i've
i've not covered that one does does that
make sense i think people are
complaining about the
nepotism of the fact that he was able to
get
uh certain jobs or certain things
through his dad being the vice president
and it would seem the emails that have
been released
that
that's kind of being corroborated now of
course i've i'm a simpleton from texas
so i try to just get smarter people that
uh talk about these things for me to
understand but i i'm having a hard time
seeing
both
sides connect on this it seems that one
is saying look he's a drug addict
nothing more the story and the other
side is saying hey that's not even the
story the story is actually all of these
other things that he was able to do
because his dad was vice president yeah
i mean i think what makes this tough is
there's an attempt being made to say
that
it's just like ivanka don jr eric and
kushner
in terms of getting stuff because his
dad was vice president it it seems to me
not even remotely equivalent i mean
trump had his kids working for him
uh ivanka was sitting in for trump uh
once when they were in
was it uh japan or
i don't even know helsinki i don't
remember when or sat in for the
secretary of state like
i think that to some degree
if you're the vice president's kid
there are going to be opportunities for
you to do things that will be given to
you and then there's a question as to
whether you do something inappropriate
or not and we we can sort of explore
that it just seems to be on a different
playing field than what trump was doing
with his kids and the very people
obsessed with hunter
said nothing and don't even care about
what was going on with kushner and
ivanka and don jr so it seems a little
bit hypocritical to me i would say
i i i can agree with that sentiment uh
what about the the issues around faculty
and the allegations of perjury yeah i
looked at that and just it didn't seem
to me that
the credib that there was credibility to
the perjury allegation
i have you know that we weren't funding
gain of function research you think that
that wasn't semantics that that's
literally the case that that there was
no american funding
in any
in any stretch of gain of function
research do you believe that that's the
case you know um how can i answer this
in in the most sort of like a relevant
way
uh i i agree with you that there's there
is a semantic component to this
in terms of how does an institution
define gain of function research
and how are republicans defining it in
this war they're waging against anthony
fauci so to some sense in some sense it
actually the semantics are sort of like
what's relevant here let me put it a
different way
i have seen
no evidence to date
that anthony fauci
was for malicious reasons
hiding the nature of what the u.s was
funding regardless of the name you
assigned to it
and i'm willing to have my mind changed
about that if someone can show me no
fauci was deliberately obfuscating he
knows he was obfuscating and the spirit
of what he was saying it not
semantically but the spirit of what he
was saying was wrong i've not seen
evidence of that today
okay this very eloquently said and i and
i very much appreciate your point of
view and uh thank you for taking my call
my pleasure alexander the texan
i might even call it a perfect phone
call quite frankly
um
very glad to exchange ideas on that
front
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely free
service at privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before it's a lifesaver
and here's how it works takes just a
couple of minutes to set up anytime you
buy something online or on the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plug-in let you give each
company a randomized virtual credit card
number that you create out of thin air
it'll even autofill the card number with
one click and the payment is taken out
of your checking account without the
merchant ever knowing your real
information so this allows you to keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create up to 12 of these virtual credit
cards a month you can set spending
limits you can freeze them you can
delete them anytime you want so when you
do this it means you're not going to be
charged when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number right after using it which for
instance i love using free trials
because i know i won't be charged when
the trial is over if i use a virtual
credit card number you're keeping your
identity private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or credit card
info protected against data breaches and
identity theft and it's free and like i
said you'll get five dollars to spend
when you sign up at privacy.com
pacman